[Music]
well we knew
because of uh seeing a lot of your
videos and seeing other and speaking to
the right amount of people that if you
buy commercial convert to resi you can
uplift value a lot more than a standard
house
yeah you've got a uh an apartment
and another apartment and another
apartment and another apartment and
another apartment yeah but you bought
the entire building
for 130 grand exactly absolutely
crazy hey what's up guys welcome back to
my channel this week i'm really really
really excited to introduce you to ryan
ryan is a musician but he's also an
extremely successful property investor
it's been really good helping him and
watching him grow his portfolio over the
last couple of years
he's doing some very big projects one
just made him
a quarter of a million pounds in fact
we're sitting in it right now
so you're gonna learn a lot from this
interview please do me a big favor
though
subscribe smash the like button uh so
you don't miss a future video
hey ryan so good to sit down and see
what you're doing yeah man it's cool to
finally flesh out some
you know some talking some ideas because
you've kind of been a little bit of a
closet
property investor yeah for the last year
or so yeah yeah yeah
just for anyone that doesn't know you
some people might recognize you um
what's your background how did we me and
what are you most well known for
so i've been in music since 2014
15. uh did fairly well in a band called
road trip um
it was self-managed and i pretty much
managed it
and came out at the back end of that and
a bit of a mess last year as
kronovirus hit um and me and you had
already
met before that and you'd and i'd seen
some of the stuff you're doing i was
just like what is this what is this like
opportunity that you're opening up to
everyone that everyone seems to be
reaping so many benefits from
about the buy refurbished refinance
strategy
i just dug into that loads man just did
all my own due diligence didn't want to
be public about anything until i knew i
was talking about
yeah so then was uh collected some
some friends who had now business
partners uh and
just went for a project and then went
for another one and then tried and
tested you know you're the strategy
which you preach and then me and you
spoke about
different ideas and um just did as much
reading as i could and as much
um speaking to people and learning and
now they've come out the other side of
it with two finished projects another
five lined up
i'm sort of like okay i'm cool to start
being a bit more public about this and
starting to spread the
good message that there's an opportunity
to be to be made if you
know where you're looking i think a lot
of people as well
don't want to speak too early but you've
done a lot bro
like the fact that it's the first time
yeah now you're speaking out
i mean the property that we're setting
right now is a commercial to residential
so this is a pub
that you bought just walk me through the
figures
because i mean i was very impressed
seeing the project um how much how much
you did you bought did you buy this this
property for
so 130 000 so 130 000 for the purchase
uh 240 on the refurbishment
refurbishment
big referrals you turned it into from
from an old pub yeah
bought it for 130 spent 240 turning it
into um apartments
five two bedroom hours big eight bedroom
hmo
so serious big projects yeah yeah in
total man 248
plus 130 you're talking about 370. is
that right
yeah yeah and then and then plus um plus
obviously you've got your illegals and
your miscellaneous and your things like
that and we work
we work in about 4 50
i think it is because it's still if you
see the video of the walk around it's
not quite finished we've got last little
bits to go
but minor cost of the grand scheme of
things and
the valuation 700k is
ridiculous which means we're pulling it
all back out so you're going to refund
to put all your money out yeah no enough
yeah
but and you've i've just been to a hmo
property of yours yeah number one yeah
yeah yeah
you bought it for how much bought that
for 75
auction 75 auction 75 both auction
actually
right how much you spend on the 75 grand
hmm 45
so until you're talking about 120 yeah
and you've just refinanced it at 145
you're gonna pull your money most of the
money out of that all back in a year 100
return which will give you a profit
just that one of a grand a month yeah so
technically now you are
financially independent now i mean yeah
you could say that but obviously we're
trying to build a slightly different
strategy to
find out already got financial
independence i'm already super happy
with my life my lifestyle
uh musician permanently like get to
pretty much do i want a daily basis
this is about building a business and
bringing my mates in
and my family and trying to build
long-term wealth that doesn't go
anywhere rather than just a few deals i
want hundreds of deals and talk to me
big
because sometimes people come to me and
they haven't got much money they don't
want to get out of their job
yeah of course that's totally different
with you you've got a very successful
musical
it's different yeah you want to grow um
what was your strongest reason
for getting into property in the first
place
um i've always wanted to i've always
loved building things
and um it sounds weird but like i always
rearranged the furniture in our house
and like built tree houses and things i
just loved
putting these physical things together
and making something and always one day
wanted to buy my own houses and do them
up but like any kid
i just assumed you couldn't do that to
your 40 50. and it was only as i started
building my own
music business and other things i
started to realize the world doesn't
quite work like that there's many other
gray areas and strategies if you know
where to go looking
for answers like samuel lid's youtube
channel and just sitting down with
a meal for you and things like that and
asking the right questions and i
realized
man you can you can go really far with
with property
if you know what you're doing and you
put the right systems in place
and then youtube uh it's funny my
youtube channel
you know one of my random videos just
blew up yeah yeah
why is this video so popular what's
going on in all of the comments it was
just road trip
yeah yeah and i think you or one of the
band members had accidentally saved one
of my videos in one of your playlists on
your
massive youtube channel with over a
million subscribers yeah there's
something one of my
videos to start what the heck probably
all these teenage girls coming in
yeah yeah but you know you've built what
you've built on the music side it's
absolutely incredible
yeah um what when we met you were in a
band
yeah called road trip um and now
what are you doing are you solo are you
still in a band and you i know
yeah yeah yeah so changes over the last
year or two yeah we went through a bit
right at the bank at the start of corona
um band dispersed for many different
reasons you can find that information
online
it is it yeah and crooked managers and
things like that but we um
we then me and my friend sonny who was
in the band we then came out of that and
created a new
like entity called feats we are
essentially a duo we just never
acknowledge it but we are a duo
me and him make music and my brother as
well helps us all content and helps run
the business and
we make a song every week and release it
every week and
we hold ourselves accountable we're
trying to do it for a year we've done 35
weeks so far
i'm not gonna lie pretty it's like cool
songs and we didn't know how to make
songs
we summer last year i'd never made a
song in my life but i've been in the
music industry five six years
building brands and singing and doing
and
recording songs but not making them not
producing them and stuff
so just set a whole new challenge to do
a song a week for a year
just to keep us entertained and keep us
going through coronavirus because of
lockdown and things like that and
um yeah it's music it's cool with music
and we're probably
you're you're a real doer yeah a lot of
people talk
and that's i think one of the reasons
we've gone because there's a lot of
talkers in all industries it's just
fluffman yeah yeah
there is a lot of that yeah but with
with property you've just got your head
down and you've been getting results
with the music and talking about it you
just literally bang bang bang
five songs out johnny yeah putting songs
out every single week i mean
that's incredible um how do you find the
time
to do your music and and
run that business and then also like
where we are right now as well where
you've got your portfolio it's all kind
of like northeast right yeah so we're in
newcastle right now
which is not close to london no so how
do you how do you manage
the time to build your property
portfolio
and and you've not done that hands-off
yeah a lot of people
that are you know musicians that are
making decent money will just throw
their money
maybe they'll just say to say to people
like me hey can you invest this for me
but you've done everything yourself yeah
you've rolled your sleeves up you've got
your hands dirty
how have you managed to do that i mean
there's certainly um there's certainly a
strategy to it uh but i
i would say before the strategy it takes
a certain mindset
um and fortunately because my parents
um blessed with a certain dna that means
you just
you work hard and you commit and if
you're doing something you go
all the way to the end and um applied
that in the music business and it worked
out and i've applied it here and now
throughout corona i've just had to
continuously just work work work work
and build and build and build
so my answer would like there's many
strategies for how you can build you
know property and do this kind of stuff
but
really you just have to learn to
sacrifice all your time if you want to
build something like especially want to
build something considerable
um and in terms of like more strategic
uh is just regular site visits as much
as you can manage but
with 10 hour return trips like you have
to squeeze time in which means not
seeing mates
as often not going to parties not doing
social things it's being corona so
that's a bit of a
weird blessing in that regard not that
corona is a blessing at all but um
it's just managing time uh i don't know
how it's
i said i don't know how it's done it's
partly down to
attitude and the person yeah i think
it's a mindset bro i think like yeah
i just don't think you can build
anything worthy about understanding what
sacrifice means and knowing like
you wake up and work until you sleep and
you get up the next day and do the same
thing and there's not a complaint
there's not like i need time off for any
of that [ __ ] like i've not done that for
seven eight years i've not had a holiday
or a time off
just build and build and build and build
until you've made something like
that people enjoy or is interesting but
i mean
and and i think it also depends on what
you want to get out so you wanna
what you're doing with the property
business very clearly i mean you've got
what seven projects
seven on the go right now two complete
and five
uh on the go one's just got planning
approved the other one's going for
planning now
so you but they're all yours you've
bought them all so you've got seven
projects some of them very big as well
yeah yeah you know we're not talking
little houses to do that in the space of
time that you've done
um and what you want to do you want to
grow a massive portfolio yeah yeah you
know so
and also to back to like what your your
whole
um like ethos is about start like anyone
can do this
and in october of 2019 i had about
six grand to my name i didn't start with
any money man like i was broke as
broke as you could be at the end of the
band and had to just
convince people and pitch to people that
you this could work
the first one being my father and then
and then raising from investors and then
you know building a story around it once
we knew what we were doing like didn't
start with any money i think is a good
point to clear up right that
obviously if i'd started with a million
pounds you could do seven projects
pretty easily right but if you if you're
starting off with nothing
uh and you're just leveraging the right
things and trying and testing the
strategies that you preach
and that other guys in in the same sort
of field preach
it does actually work it's really weird
it just works
uh it's crazy six grand it's kind of
crazy because
you built quite a big successful thing
really with the bands
i
i made no money for all that time i just
put it back into the business
and there's a whole other thing that
went on like it got very sticky towards
the end
and all of this is online by the way if
people want to go dig out you can find
out what actually happened but um
essentially
it all got ripped away um by a certain
entity
and left with nothing left in debt and
that's how started the property business
in debt with a liability for two months
rent on a gaff that was like six grand a
month with
a load of other debt like just it was so
messy left to me and sonny
my brother to sort out and then off the
back of that
learn how to make music release a summer
week and then build a property portfolio
and it's a pandemic
i i don't know how the last year's like
manifested
and how you've gone from that to having
seven projects on the go yeah yeah i
mean this one
has made you what quarter a quarter of a
million pounds
[Music]
of course we want to show this works
yeah and it does
so you got this um talking through them
what happened and how you bought it and
yeah with this with this project which
is a pub conversion it's a pub
conversion it's the first one we bought
um and may call it naivete i don't know
what it was that what that made us think
a pub is a good idea to start
to start from but we'd heard you say
actually quite a few videos
um that it doesn't matter about the size
of the property it's all the same
headache really
and because it was 130 grand it was
about the same price as just a standard
house around here really
so we were like why don't we get that
because the chances are we can uplift
value massively
um back when we didn't really know what
the sus was
um and then got an auction two minutes
before the auction close before the
auction started we've got a pre-auction
uh two minutes before the auction
started and then it went to the front do
that did you just
say to the said to the auctioneer or the
estate agent you said
your final offer before auction yeah
yeah
well we we try to get it for 110
pre-auction
and we were so close to getting it and
they but because it was
only a few days before the auction uh
they came
back after a few days of considering and
went no but the day before the auction
and then we had hours until it hit 5 30
when the auction closes and
when they open it would be listed in the
auction the next day
so two minutes before literally i've got
a screenshot on my on my phone somewhere
of the email that is uh us submitting
and accepting right we'll go for the 130
asking
because we thought the 20 grand
difference was a lot at the time yeah
not knowing how much this thing was
going to
uplift in value worth 700 700 yeah
no i had no idea so we um we thought it
was worth squeezing the 20k it just
wouldn't have really mattered as much in
the end
uh and didn't um and then two minutes
before the auction we got the email back
from them that said okay yeah
all confirmed we've got the money like
because we had to send across the uh
deposit
and uh and we were like oh [ __ ] it's
starting like
now you've got 30 days to complete and
then it's a project it's a pub
like what do we do we've done as much
due diligence as we could had builders
looking at everything
but it's a whole different ball game
like doing all the pr the preliminaries
is different to then
being like oh now you've got it there's
only so much preparation you can do you
have to
have to show me and what you've done
you've done a lot of due diligence
and and you are a thoughtful person but
you're also a massive action taker so
you've been
been earning and learning kind of at the
same time
as you go yeah it's okay so you bought
it uh how long does it take then start
to finish to complete the refurb
12 months but um it should have taken
nine
but obviously the kronor is just screwed
up and you got a commercial valuation on
this
how did you feel when the value came up
bear in mind you bought it for 130
it spent 240 on it so you're only about
370 in when the valuation came in
at 700 how did you feel
well we'd halfway through not halfway
through the project but
toward the end of last year we got 590
on it
from the lender and we were like okay
whoa
like 600 but mad we were expecting mid
40s maybe 500
mid 500s if we're like lucky when we got
590 we were just like mad and we got a
610
and then we got seven five oh cause you
were buying each bit on each stage yeah
yeah just to manage risk as we go
yeah um yeah see slightly expensive way
doing it business stage
yeah yeah exactly yeah and then um 700k
and we were just like
i mean it's fortunate that it it went up
to that level because we'd overspent by
maybe 40 50
because of the delays in corona there's
nothing we could have done like we had
to spend that money
and the main supply they wouldn't do it
for like four months they had to close
off the road eventually when they did it
uh
just so many delays and of the bridging
finance obviously rolling up as we
were going along pointlessly so a lot of
mistakes but learned a lot and because
of the uplift and the cheap price it
meant we could make those mistakes in a
learning curve so we kind of incubated
the perfect
learning scenario do you know what i
mean what are the other projects that
you've got going on
so we've got these two which is five two
bed flats eight bed
eight bed hmo and fiber hmo they're
they're now pretty much on the market
one of them is on the market this is
going on the market like as we speak
um and then we've got an eight bed hmo
which we've
secured literally up the road um and
that's gone to planning so it's
currently a three bed house
uh it's big it's got the double fronted
and we know we can get eight beds out of
it
um that we'll get that that's a good
location
as well with the uh buying just outside
article four areas yeah yeah
turning them into hmos we know that
article four is gonna ripple through
exactly
the grandfather right so you're winning
on the rent you're winning on the fourth
capital appreciation
you're winning on the on the planet it's
like every which way
yeah yeah you're smashing it yeah okay
so you've got so you've got a few hmos
you've got this massive project yeah
what are the big things have you got
going on
we've got another seven bed hmm
wakefield that's
past planning this week that's gonna
start june and then
the other big ones we've got another pub
that we're tendering
at the moment uh which is basically a
2.0 of this
it's cheap it's going to uplift mad it's
going to be a great project and we've
already had the bill to check out
i've already discussed some terms with
the agent who's going to get back
tomorrow we'll get that one
i'm sure we'll get it and then the other
one is
project further south of here and that's
a nine and a half thousand square foot
and we've just secured that
65 grand below asking price and that
will be
it's maybe twice the size of this pub
which would be
that would be some so you're fully a
fully pledged property developer now
then
i i wouldn't consider i wouldn't
consider myself like anything really
other than that then i've
i've done some projects and i feel like
i know what i'm doing now
but that's that's that's all i feel i
just feel like i know what i'm doing and
i know what my business needs to do
and what we're up to um but like beyond
that i don't i don't really know what's
what's gonna happen i'm just excited to
keep building and to keep bringing in
new projects and to keep looking at
things differently and
trying new strategies what what's next
then so what do you hope in the next
year or two i'm gonna look like well
we've targeted um
by the end of 2022 we won 25 projects
and 35 grand cash flow each month net is
where we want to be that's our
target as a as a business and as uh
personally that was what will give us
the
freedom we we want um uh to then like
move wherever we want in
in the property like realm um not
necessarily that we need the cash flow
uh for our personal lives but it gives
you that flexibility within the business
to start making much bigger decisions
and like
where do we want to go with it 10 grand
a month would be nice but like
doesn't really solve much for us because
of
the nature of property is quite
expensive takes a lot of cash but when
we
when we can start doing 25 35 50 grand a
month
you know you can start doing a big
project every year that's just yours
as well as using investors money which
we are open to do
and do do i mean you know my advice to
you
which i've said which is you've done it
yourself now yeah you know what you're
doing
you've taken due diligence you've got a
really good team i mean we've been
speaking
for probably about nearly two years
something like that yeah yeah
this has been in the planning yeah yeah
you've now done it if you wanted to
scale up i absolutely reckon
bring other investors in yeah yeah and
um and scout that way you know what
you're doing
you've got a really really good team i
mean you've had some
troubles you had to fight some builders
yeah yeah yeah
tell me about some of the some of the
some of the problems that you've had
well
the i guess the main thing would it's
our fault i'd love to put it on to the
builders we should have been way more
uh we should have ran way more due
diligence when we were bringing in
builders
you just kind of assume when you're
starting out that you know they're a
builder and you've met them
you trust them we spoke to these guys
loads and that we've walked around the
property with them
we just just like you know you just at
some point you just trust people
but uh you just need to make sure people
are compliant and that they understand
so what did they do
well it's a hmo that that was the
conversion and they just didn't know how
to meet hmo standards and hate smoke
appliance
so we were we ended up having to redo
some of the project with another builder
which is a waste of time and money
obviously so they just weren't doing it
to a standard which was going to be fit
for
exactly would it be fine if it was by
standing by to let but you have to have
the
the right fire eggs and the right you
know everything is different with the
hmo
and how often do you travel up the
northeast
um at the moment
it's probably like every two weeks or
something um
but it's gonna be only because we've
just completed two like these are
finished now i've not needed to be here
but
we've got three they're going to start
in june and that's big and they're big
ones as well so
when they start i'd imagine it's it's
going to be every week twice a week or
something got a lot going on and you
literally drive down and back in the day
which i still don't understand yeah
yeah i don't i don't watch the idea of
staying overnight and then waking up the
next day being like cool now i've got a
five hour travel i'd rather just have
the worst day of travelling
but then wake up next day yeah yeah so
okay so whereabouts you live in you live
in
london yeah yeah right um what have been
some of the biggest lessons there's some
of the
you know tips to share with other people
if you were advising yourself yeah
two years prior yeah what would you what
would you say
i would say although i'm all about just
do it and go for it don't start with a
pub
don't start the pub conversion unless
you really know your [ __ ]
we i don't know if we got lucky i don't
really believe in luck i think you
manifest your own luck but
there's definitely things that could
have happened here that didn't that
would have
potentially finished a project like we
would have been screwed like like the
main supply could have been way more
than it was and
all this other kind of stuff um and
not that i think any of that is a likely
issue on another project
but the fact that we didn't even know
how to ask those questions
means i wouldn't wouldn't have taken
that risk in hindsight but that's the
that's the great thing about
you know naivety in a way isn't it that
you you can do really like risky things
without even knowing
um so i would say manage risk from the
start
more wisely start with a smaller project
just to learn stuff
which was the benefit of doing the hmo
the fiber hm at the same time
we were learning loads of mistakes with
that one yeah adapting them for this one
and then using that knowledge when we're
acquiring new ones
yeah it's so weird though because our
conversations now about property
we speak such different conversations
yeah so when we first met
on our dinner um now we speak on the
same level
yeah yeah but it was then it was like
hey chen what
when i met you i was asking all about
rent to rent
i was like what i thought yeah yeah you
you were like you got terrible
and when i explained my scenario so some
people that stuff works really well
but for me you're like you're just not
going to work for us
your time is not going to you're not
going to do it and i was like okay
interesting and it's
those little ideas man they lead you
down paths where you go oh okay and then
you think of a whole new scenario yeah
and then we'd flesh that out and it
would i forgot about that but yeah you
did i want to do restaurants
and i remember saying don't do it
because i was broke i need money and i
was like
i gotta buy a house bro i was like how
do i get into the rent to rent stuff
yeah um now you didn't do rent to rent
oh man
i would just now just for me it wouldn't
work during rent to rent
uh and i'm fortunate enough to be in a
position where my father is
part of the business as well obviously
great girl yeah
he's an absolute character he's a proper
legend and he's he's spent his
um life and business in london raising
finance and
work with big family wealth and stuff
and it's been instrumental obviously
in supporting what uh what we do in the
business but
him like me didn't know anything about
the strategies hmo was like what so we
still had to learn from scratch
yeah um and still started with bare
minimum money but it just meant that
when we were up and
running we knew how to scale it we were
like okay now it's a business let's
scale it
rather than uh just be like okay how do
we scramble the next hmo or something
like that
people might say you know oh you got a
bit lucky because of this that and the
other one with the pub
you've got your dad and you happen to
have me meet samuel yeah and just like
the other but it's
like you create your own luck yeah you
know you put yourself in the right place
at the right time
you could have you know been been
licking your wounds after the whole
thing
exactly locked down oh well isn't life
hard but instead
during that year which by the way a lot
of people said 2020 was a write-off
yeah yeah and i went on facebook oh this
is a write-off
so you'd have the issues with your band
didn't we're left with not a lot of
money at all
you know coronavirus can't perform
contour
yeah and and you made 2020 probably the
most successful year of your life i
would imagine
i made the best i brought a cat as well
in 2020 well
i mean definitely the best possibly the
best thing i ever did i love my cat um
but no i made a lot of
a lot of serious decisions in 2020. and
i started 2020 off actually
i publicly said um to quite a few books
i was so fed up of the way
things were happening that i was just
like you know what this year i'm just
gonna be ruthless
like this year i'm just getting [ __ ]
done like i'm not
worrying so much about the people around
me like and catering for all their needs
and stuff i was just like now i'm just i
need to do me at some point and yeah and
it just shows man if you just focus on
something and just set a roof for the
skull and go for it
pretty much anything's anything's
possible i mean you create your own life
you write your own book of life yeah um
but most people give someone else the
pen no you can write my life but
actually yeah
you've got it you've got to take that
you do but some people like that some
people want that some people want
someone else to govern everything they
do and
i can appreciate that i just don't um
it's not wired that way
if you're not wired that way you can't
really like understand it
as much you know what i mean but if some
people want that that's fine some people
want two hmos some people want to
just make a few songs some people like
working their nine to five like
i just want to do live from my own terms
as you do and most people
should should do i think should want to
live on their own terms and
live prosperously and like never worry
about money that's the saddest thing
when people worry about money
which is what property can do for you it
can make you not have to worry about
money because it doesn't take much time
once you've got it up and running or if
you do it wrong can make you worry more
about money yeah
it can yeah
finished it right but i mean so many
mistakes were made it's like that like
always happened though yeah yeah here's
my advice like i think i said this to
you when we first met
a big deal on a small here will make
would take just a bit effort yeah
so this pod conversion which you've made
a quarter of a million pound profit
i know was less work than you'll have to
mow down the road
right yeah yeah however so you might say
well why don't you just do big deals
when you're starting out you're gonna
make a lot of mistakes yeah sometimes
you're better off to make the stakes on
smaller than a big deal
so what my advice is start small and
then build your way up bigger and bigger
and bigger
so for you now i personally wouldn't be
doing small projects now i'd only be
doing big stuff
yeah yeah i've been bringing other
people in um you know what you've done
is incredible
i'm really inspired as well actually
because i think that's the figures and
seeing what you've done in newcastle
newcastle's a great place
i'm really excited about newcastle as a
city and i'm also really grateful that
you've you know you've let me sit down
and interview you
and and talk through the uh oh mate
don't even like it's funny how
both ways this works like it starts off
by me going [ __ ] what's this what are
you doing like
i'm inspired by what you're doing and
what you're saying and now like it comes
full circle didn't it when you
like work on something and yeah well now
we and that's what that's what friends
should differentially inspire each other
yeah friendship pull each other up
uh but also i know i've been i've been
kind of banging on you about
put stuff out so it's great that now
you're able to do that you've never
you've got a website that's about to
launch by the time this comes out
hopefully yeah yeah
yeah whatever it's called yet it'll be
beaumont and partners
something we haven't established in the
description
thank you man um so final words of
advice
someone watching this that's thinking
you know what maybe maybe they're a
musician yeah we've had quite a few
musicians that we worked with
um or or maybe they're they're not maybe
they're thinking
about doing rental rates they've got six
grand but anyone that's thinking about
stepping into the realm of property yeah
it doesn't know much like you didn't a
couple years ago
what advice would you give them getting
into it
i would say um speak to sam
speak to sound but i'd say honestly uh
sounds you know
maybe a bit too far-fetched but there's
be it's easy to sit here now with a
finished
uh pub conversion um or like you with
the castle and things like that it's
easy to sit there and be like yeah no
yeah we've done this and it's
it's made us loads of money and it's
great but like there's so many junctures
down like through the journey where we
were like [ __ ]
like there's so many mistakes there's so
many bad things happening like
that is just the nature of it there's so
many things are going to go wrong don't
be intimidated by that
a lot like except those things are going
to happen no matter how much you prepare
that mistakes are gonna happen put the
systems in place manage your downside
and just accept that mistakes will
happen and just
find solutions find answers then you can
sit with a finished pub conversion or
whatever it is and
be happy about it like that's great well
hey dude really inspired thanks so much
thank you very much appreciate you guys
i think you can
appreciate how much miranda's done and
how incredible and inspirational stories
stories please do me a massive favor
smash the like button also you're going
to see some more videos with ryan coming
up real soon if you want to subscribe to
the channel you can do that up right
here
you want to see a playlist of literally
over a hundred people
that are smashing it in property just
like ryan is gonna do a whole playlist
right here thanks so much for watching
and i look forward to seeing you next
time
[Music]